This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养坚韧意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回首当年》播客。对1979年来说，那对我是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论20世纪80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回首当年》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《知难而进》。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today's episode is for all of my late bloomers, all my late bloomers out there who are in their 20s living deeply fulfilling lives, going at their own pace, experiencing life fully, but feeling like all of it kind of means nothing because they have never been in a relationship
大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们身处世界何地。非常高兴你们能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析我们20多岁的心理。今天的节目献给所有大器晚成的人，献给所有20多岁、生活极其充实、按自己的节奏前行、充分体验生活，却觉得这一切都没有意义的人，因为你们从来没有过一段恋爱关系
before. They've never really dated. They've never been kissed, been in love, had the kind of intimate experiences everyone else is seemingly having and they are feeling well they're feeling left behind let's not sugarcoat it it's really really tough being a late bloomer is hard our 20s are confusing enough without feeling like there is this thing we are constantly waiting to finally happen and life just hasn't really started until it has you know love is this wonderful beautiful life-changing thing and so we're when it hasn't been a part of your story so far, you can feel like, A, you failed, B, you're missing out, and perhaps C, perhaps it will never be on the cards for you, perhaps it is never going to happen.
之前。你们从来没有真正约会过。你们从来没有接过吻，谈过恋爱，体验过其他人似乎都在经历的那种亲密关系，你们觉得——好吧，你们觉得被抛弃了，我们别粉饰太平了，真的，真的很难，做一个大器晚成的晚熟者很难，在我们20多岁的时候，如果没有那种我们一直在苦苦等待、直到它终于发生人生才算真正开始的感觉，生活本身就已经够让人困惑的了，你知道，爱情是一种美妙、美丽、改变人生的事物，所以当它迄今为止还没有成为你故事的一部分时，你可能会觉得，A，你失败了，B，你错过了很多，也许C，也许它永远不会属于你，也许它永远不会发生。
And that in itself, it's such a scary thought. So I'm really just here to assure you, this is my primary goal today, that none of the above is true. You are not a failure, you are not completely missing out on life. And just because it hasn't happened yet, doesn't mean that it never will. The past is not a prediction of the future in this case. We've been told all these things about when we should date, what love should feel like, why you need to be having sex and flings, why time is running out for you, you know, that you should be looking for a relationship.
而这本身，就是一个极其可怕的想法。所以我今天的主要目的，就是向你保证，以上所说的一切都不是真的。你不是一个失败者，你并没有完全错开生活。而且它现在还没发生，并不意味着它永远不会发生。在这种情况下，过去并不能预测未来。我们被灌输了关于我们什么时候应该约会、爱情应该是什么感觉、为什么你需要有性爱和短暂恋情、为什么你的时间不多了的所有这些事情，你知道，你本该去寻找一段恋爱关系。
But when we slow it down, your biggest focus in your 20s should be you. A relationship, a romantic history, it says absolutely nothing about your work. earth or where you're going. And I think that it should be nothing more than a bonus to an already fabulous life that you've created for yourself. So I really want to help you. If you are a late bloomer, struggling with the fact that a relationship just hasn't been in your timeline yet. I really want today's episode to allow you to go forward with a little bit more ease, a little bit more grace, a little bit less comparison and just full acceptance that things have worked out the way they needed to and they will continue to unfold in the best possible way that might include love that's just around
但当我们慢下来时，你在20多岁时最大的重心应该放在你自己身上。一段感情、一段浪漫的历史，对你的价值或你将要去向何方绝对没有任何说明。我认为它不过是你为自己创造的已经极其精彩的生活的一个额外奖励。所以我真的很想帮助你。如果你是一个大器晚成的人，正在纠结于感情为何迟迟没有出现在你的时间表上。我真的很希望今天的节目能让你带着更多一点的轻松、更多一点的优雅、少一点的比较，以及完全接受事情已经按需要的方式发展，并且将继续以最佳可能的方式展开的态度继续前行，这可能包括就在不远处的爱情
the corner in a couple of weeks it may include love that's around the corner in a couple of years but having confidence in who you are having confidence in your future in your dating experience knowing that it will happen that is the most important. thing that you can have right now. It's actually probably more important than a relationship, having confidence in yourself and knowing that you can handle it no matter what happens. So without further ado, there is way too much in this episode for me to keep rambling. This is a huge episode. One I have waited so long to do when we're finally getting to it. So let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
几周内，可能包括几年后就在不远处的爱情，但对你是谁充满信心，对你的未来充满信心，对你的约会经验充满信心，知道它会发生，这才是最重要的。你可以拥有的东西。这其实可能比拥有一段恋情更重要，对自己有信心，并知道无论发生什么你都能应付自如。废话不多说，这一集的内容实在太多了，我不能再唠叨了。这是一个巨大的主题。我等了这么久才做，现在我们终于要开始了。让我们切入正题。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier,
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养坚韧意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透那些主导着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来蜕变，成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金有什么鬼关系？好吧，你可以在《回首当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table. right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊当天的可卡因，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it
是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请收听《回首当年》
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上。欢迎来到我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年来
of my own experience in the mental health field, and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某个东西时，我们会如此全神贯注于追逐的过程，以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring, inconsistent. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的明显漏洞。这引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上
or wherever you get your podcasts. All right, Tame. Let's start at the very beginning. what is a late bloomer? Well, I actually think there are two ways of seeing it. A late bloomer can be, of course, a developmental term. It can also be a feeling. So the first kind of definition, in healthcare and medicine,
收听《情网难逃》播客。好了，各位。让我们从最初开始，什么是大器晚成者？嗯，我其实觉得有两种看待方式。大器晚成当然可以是一个发展学上的术语。它也可以是一种感觉。所以第一种定义，在医疗保健和医学中，
late bloomer is a term to describe a child who is essentially not meeting certain developmental milestones when they should. You know, you bring your little baby, your little infant, into a doctor's office and they say, oh, can they talk yet? Are they babbling? can they walk yet? And if the answer is no one, they should be, they say, oh, they're a late bloomer. They're taking their time. You kind of get the picture. This term is based on the assumption that our
大器晚成是一个用来描述在应有的年龄基本上没有达到某些特定发展里程碑的孩子的术语。你知道，你把你的小宝贝、小婴儿带到医生的办公室，他们会说，哦，他会说话了吗？他在咿呀学语吗？他会走路了吗？如果答案是没有，而在他们应该会的时候，他们就会说，哦，他是个大器晚成者。他不急。你大概能明白这幅画了。这个术语基于这样的假设：我们
progress through life, through childhood, adolescence, adulthood should be measurable, predictable. And as human beings, we should all follow a very similar path. When we aren't, well, then there is something quote unquote wrong with us that needs to be seen to. There's something that needs to be fixed. Hopefully you see where I'm going with this. You know, there really isn't a predictable way that we all go through life, but, you know, for the sake of childhood development, maybe that is true. When we are quite young, there is a very rigid way of seeing our physical and cognitive development, but slowly as we get older, that also that rigidity, that inflexibility, that timeline starts to also apply to our social development and the relational or interpersonal milestones that we should be
在生命中、在童年、青春期、成年期的进展应该是可测量的、可预测的。作为人类，我们都应该遵循一条非常相似的路径。如果我们没有，那么，我们身上就有某种所谓的不对劲的地方，需要被关注。有些地方需要修复。希望你们明白我的意思。你知道，我们经历人生其实并没有一条可预测的途径，但是，为了儿童发展的需要，这或许是真的。当我们相当年轻的时候，看待我们身体和认知发展的方式是非常死板的，但慢慢地随着我们变老，这种死板、这种不灵活、这种时间表也开始适用于我们的社交发展，以及我们在十几岁和二十多岁时应该达到的关系或人际关系里程碑——“应该”是这里最重要的词。而且人们有一种信念，如果你还没有过初吻，你还没有过性行为，在那些成长岁月的某个特定时期之前你还没有过你的第一段恋情，同样，有什么地方不对劲。你身上出了问题。
hitting in our teens and 20s should being the most important word here. And there is this belief that if you haven't had your first kiss, you haven't had sex, you haven't had your first relationship by a certain period during those formative years, again, something is wrong. Something's wrong with you. obviously if you cannot tell by the tone of my voice, I believe this is false. But it leads me to the second way of seeing the term late bloomer. And that's not so much as a definition as we would have it in childhood. It's as a feeling. Being a late bloomer is an individual appraisal and feeling of being behind.
显然，如果你听不出我语气中的意思，我认为这是假的。但这引导我走向看待“大器晚成”这个词的第二种方式。这与其说是一个像我们在童年时期那样的定义，不如说是一种感觉。作为一个大器晚成的晚熟者，是一种个人对“落后”的评估和感觉。
Like when you look at your life and you look at the norm, the norm is further ahead than you are when it comes to some special event or thing that you think should have happened to by now. There's one problem with this, of course, which is that with possibly millions, almost probably like dozens of millions of other people, the same age as you are now, across all continents and countries, there is no way to know exactly what the norm is based on all of those averages. There is actually no way to know if you are truly behind. We tend to just base it off of a skewed sample of those around us and what the media or other influences are telling us. And it often ends up making us feel terrible. The second point I want to make
就像当你审视自己的生活，并将其与常态进行对比时，当涉及到某些你认为应该在现在已经发生的事情或特殊事件时，常态比你要超前。这当然有一个问题，那就是，可能有数百万、几乎可能有几千万个与你现在同龄的其他人，遍布各大洲和国家，根本无法根据所有这些平均值确切地知道常态是什么。事实上，根本无法知道你是否真的落后了。我们往往只是根据周围人的一份有偏差的样本，以及媒体或其他影响者告诉我们的东西来得出结论。这最终往往会让我们感觉糟糕透顶。我想在这里提出的第二点是，那又怎样？那又怎样？
here is, so what? So what? The norm is not where you are. Why does that really matter? If this is the pace that you've gone at, if this is your life story and no one else's, if this is just how it's worked out, if you're happy, why does it matter if the norm is further ahead? If other people have made different choices than you. Let's talk about the two main ways that we can kind of feel like a late bloomer or feel behind in our 20s. The first one is, of course, relationships, specifically never having been in one, but also never having dated, never having had that kind of intimate connection with someone,
常态并不在你所在的地方。这到底有什么大不了的？如果这是你前进的节奏，如果这是你的人生故事而不是别人的，如果事情就是这样发展的，如果你很开心，常态比你走得更远又有什么关系呢？如果其他人做出了与你不同的选择。让我们来谈谈在我们20多岁时，让我们觉得自己是个大器晚成者或觉得自己落后的两种主要方式。第一种当然是恋爱关系，具体来说是从来没有谈过恋爱，但也包括从来没有约会过，从来没有和某人有过那种亲密联系，
never having had that intimacy. Because we see relationships and attraction and love as such a reflection of ourselves. And as a society, we put dating on a pedestal, it can sometimes feel like if it hasn't happened yet, something we must be going about it wrong. We are unattractive. We must be undesirable, not funny, not confident enough, not enough. Because everyone else has figured out how to do it, but we haven't. We can also feel like equally like we're missing out, especially during our 20s and during this
从来没有过那种亲密感。因为我们将人际关系、吸引力和爱情视为对我们自己的某种反映。而且作为一个社会，我们将约会奉上神坛，有时它会让人觉得如果它还没有发生，我们一定是在用错误的方式对待它。我们没有吸引力。我们一定令人讨厌、不够有趣、不够自信、还不够格。因为其他人已经弄清楚了怎么做，而我们还没有。我们也会同样感到自己错过了什么，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，在这个
decade where there is a lot of chatter and a lot of conversations around relationships. And it's this big storyline that we're all kind of obsessed with during this decade. You know, often it's portrayed to us as if there is something very sacred contained in the relationship experience. And if you haven't had the chance to experience it yet, well, you're missing out. And of course, when that's the way that you're made to feel, you want it even more. As the saying goes, you know, humans want what they can't have. And so it's not uncommon to feel maybe jealous or envious or frustrated even at your coupled friends or to sometimes, yeah, believe that your life would be so much better and you'd finally be happier if it would just finally happen for you.
充斥着关于人际关系的闲聊和讨论的十年里。这是我们在这一十年中都有些痴迷的宏大故事线。你知道，通常它向我们呈现的画面是，在恋爱经历中蕴含着某种非常神圣的东西。如果你还没有机会体验它，好吧，你就错过了。当然，当这就是你被灌输的感觉时，你会更加渴望它。俗话说得好，你知道，人们总是想要他们得不到的东西。所以，对那些成双成对的朋友感到嫉妒、羡慕甚至是沮丧，或者有时真的相信如果它最终能在你身上发生，你的生活就会变得更好、你终于会更快乐，这并不是什么罕见的事。
So there's a great deal of longing and there's also a great deal of insecurity, which is totally normal. It also certainly doesn't help that our society, oh by gosh, do they love to single shame. In fact, a study done at a UK university a couple of years ago that I quote quite a lot, it examined single shaming and it found that statements like, oh, you know, all the good ones will be taken soon or statements like you're just too picky or being given unsolicited advice as a single person. That's part of the single shaming experience and it can actually cause people to rush into relationships quicker, but they found that these same relationships end up disintegrating sooner because the person that you pick out of desperation is probably not going to be
所以这其中有很大程度的渴望，也有很大程度的不安全感，这是完全正常的。而且我们的社会——天哪，他们太喜欢羞辱单身人士了。事实上，几年前英国一所大学做过一项我经常引用的研究，它调查了单身羞辱，发现诸如“哦，你知道，所有优质的人很快都会被挑光”这样的话，或者像“你只是太挑剔了”这样的话，或者作为单身人士被动接受未经请求的建议。这都是单身羞辱体验的一部分，它实际上会导致人们更快地冲进一段恋情，但他们发现这些同样的恋情最终会更快地解体，因为你出于绝望而挑选的人可能不会是
the right person for you. But again, there's no. judgment here. You're facing this weird catch-22. You feel like you're a failure if you're alone, but if you were to date just anyone and settle, you wouldn't be happy either. Tough, really tough. I actually asked you all over on Instagram to share your experiences with this because I think we can learn the most from people going through it with us. And there was this one story that illustrated this struggle very, very well. This came from a little. listener called Chavon who lives in Ireland. Ireland? Sorry, my Australian accent makes that hard to say. Anyways, Chavon. I'm 27 and I've never been in a long-term relationship, but I feel so ready.
对的人。但再说一次，这里没有评判。你面临着这个奇怪的进退两难的困境。你觉得自己如果单身就是个失败者，但如果你随便和谁约会并凑合着过，你也不会快乐。很难，真的很难。我其实在Instagram上问过大家分享你们对此的经历，因为我觉得我们可以从和我们经历相同事情的人身上学到最多。有一个故事把这种挣扎描绘得非常非常生动。这是一个住在爱尔兰的小听众沙文分享的。爱尔兰？抱歉，我的澳大利亚口音让这个词很难发音。无论如何，沙文。我27岁了，从来没有过长期恋爱经历，但我感觉自己太准备好了。
It feels like I'm waiting until I find love for my life to start, but I don't want it to be just anyone. I'm the last of my friends to date. Some of my friends are even married. And for the people who don't understand what that feels like. Imagine going out with all your friends and they all get let into an exclusive club whilst you have to sit outside. Sometimes they'll come out of the club and sit with you for a little bit, but they always end up going back in whilst you were never let inside. At the end of the night, they talk about how fun it was and have all these stories and you're sitting there thinking, I can't relate to any of this, but I so desperately wish I could. That's what it feels like to be the last single friend. I switch between feeling extremely desperate and also wanting to
感觉我一直在等待找到真爱，我的生活才能开始，但我不想随便找个人。我是朋友中最后一个约会的人。我有些朋友甚至都结婚了。对于那些不理解这种感觉的人来说。想象一下，和所有的朋友一起出去玩，他们都被放进了一个独家俱乐部，而你却不得不坐在外面。有时他们会从俱乐部出来陪你坐一会儿，但他们总是会回到里面去，而你却从未被允许进去。在深夜结束时，他们谈论着玩得有多开心，有着各种各样的故事，而你坐在那里心想，这一切我都无法感同身受，但我多么多么希望我能。这就是成为最后一个单身朋友的感觉。我在感到极其绝望和想要
take my time. But I worry that as I get older, I'll never get to have this experience and I'm running out of time. I'll never get to have those feelings and that makes me so beyond depressed to think about. I just want to join the club. Oh my gosh, Chauvonne, that last line, I just want to join that club, that sentence. That hit me. Because I think we. We. have all in some capacity been there. That's such a human experience. I remember exactly what that felt like wanting to know everyone's stories, wanting to know everyone's dating stories and relationship stories so that I was prepared, but equally not wanting them to know I couldn't participate in the conversation the way that they were because I didn't have any of those stories of my own
慢慢来之间摇摆不定。但我担心随着年龄的增长，我将永远无法拥有这种经历，我的时间不多了。我将永远无法拥有那些感觉，一想到这我就沮丧得无以复加。我只是想加入那个俱乐部。天哪，沙文，最后那句话，我只想加入那个俱乐部，那句话。直击我的心灵。因为我想我们。所有人都。在某种程度上经历过。那是一种非常人性化的体验。我清楚地记得那种感觉，想要知道每个人的故事，想要知道每个人的约会故事和恋爱故事，这样我好有所准备，但同样又不想让他们知道我无法像他们那样参与对话，因为我没有任何属于我自己的那些故事
and feeling like everyone was part of this like secret society and I just like didn't have access to the secrets yet. It's really, really hard, especially when it makes it hard to relate to other people as well, and especially when you don't have other single friends or you don't have other late bloomer friends who you can sometimes just like, you know, relish in the pity with. Sometimes you just want to feel shit with someone else by your side. Let's talk about another aspect of being a late bloomer in your 20s, and that is virginity. Being in your 20s and not having had sex yet, can feel like there is a big banner above your head and everyone knows and everyone's judging you and you're judging you and again the debate is between do i wait or do i just get it over with
并且觉得每个人都是这个秘密社团的一部分，而我只是还没有权限接触到这些秘密。这真的非常非常难，尤其是当它也让你很难与其他人产生共鸣时，尤其是当你没有其他单身朋友或大器晚成的朋友，可以偶尔和他们一起，你知道，去品味那种遗憾的时候。有时候你只是想身边有个人陪你一起感觉糟糕透顶。让我们来谈谈20大器晚成的另一个方面，那就是处女情结。在20多岁时还没有过性行为，可能会让人觉得你的头顶上挂着一块巨大的横幅，每个人都知道，每个人都在评判你，而你也在评判你自己，同样，这其中的纠结在于：我是该等待，还是干脆把它“了结”了？
it feels like if you didn't have sex as a teenager you must have been lame or uncool or unattractive or undesirable and now if you would have sex the person would know that you don't know what you're doing i'm going to say this right now most people when it comes to sex in their 20s don't know what they're doing anyways. So you don't have to worry about that. It's also important to say, people don't have sex for so many reasons. Health reasons, religious reasons, asexuality, personal choice, because they want it to be meaningful. That's a good enough reason as any. Any of those reasons are good reasons, plus many, many more. You know, I had another DM from someone talking about how their friends, like the reason it was so hard to talk about being a virgin or
感觉如果你在青少年时期没有发生过性关系，你一定很逊、很不酷、没有吸引力或不受欢迎，而现在如果你发生了性关系，对方就会知道你根本不知道自己在做什么。我现在就说这个：大多数人在20多岁经历性行为时，本来就都不知道自己在做什么。所以你根本不用担心这个。同样重要的是要说，人们不发生性行为有很多很多原因。健康原因、宗教原因、无性恋、个人选择，因为他们希望这段经历是有意义的。这是一个足够好的理由。任何这些理由都是好理由，还有更多更多理由。你知道，我收到过另一个人的私信，谈到为什么他们的朋友——为什么谈论作为处女或
acknowledge it in their 20s was because their friends would always put pressure on them on nights out to just just get it over with and they would push her towards random guys and men and they would go up to them and tell them that she was a virgin which had me like gobb a smacked gobboggleat I don't even have words like I'm literally speechless even talking about that because that is quite frankly disgusting like that's disgusting why was it any of their business and why was like her virginity, some fun little party trick that they could get drunk and play with. You know, I just think that's awful. And in all honesty, I wish I'd waited.
在20多岁时承认这一点会如此困难，因为他们的朋友在晚上外出时总是向他们施加压力，让他们“干脆把这事了结了”，她们会把她推向随便的男生和男人，她们会走过去告诉那些人她是个处女，这让我惊掉下巴。惊掉下巴，我甚至说不出话来，我简直无言以对，甚至在谈论这件事时也是如此，因为这坦率地说令人作呕——这太令人作呕了。这关她们什么事，为什么她的处女性质，能成为她们喝醉后可以玩弄的某种有趣的小派对把戏。你知道，我只是觉得这太糟糕了。老实说，我希望当初我选择等待。
I'm somewhat envious of those who have and now get to make an informed decision with a more developed brain about when they want to have sex with someone. You know, my first time was such a bad experience and it definitely damaged my relationship with sex for some time. I remember thinking, why did I do that? Why did I do that with that person? And it was because I felt like everyone else around me was doing it. And I didn't want to be left out. I didn't want to fall behind. I didn't want everyone else to look at me and say, well, something's wrong with you. You're not part of the club. And as someone who just got it over with, it was a huge mistake. Choosing not to have sex or
我有点嫉妒那些曾经等待过、现在能够用更成熟的大脑对何时与某人发生性关系做出明智决定的人。你知道，我的第一次是一次非常糟糕的经历，它在一段时间内确实损害了我对性行为的态度。我记得当时在想，我为什么要这么做？我为什么要跟那个人做这种事？那是因为我觉得周围的所有人都在这么做。我不想被落下。我不想落后。我不希望其他人看着我然后说，好吧，你身上一定有什么毛病。你不是我们这个圈子的人。而作为一个“干脆把这事了结了”的人，那是一个巨大的错误。选择不发生性行为，或者
just not having it because you haven't had it yet, says no more about your self-worth than having had a lot of sex. Honestly, we need to talk about virginity shaming more during this decade, more during our 20s, and even in our 30s as well, because A, virginity shaming, much like single shaming, is so rife. And B, it's just quite frankly a weird thing to do. It's a weird thing to shame someone for what they've chosen to do with their body. Sometimes I do find, that the sex positivity movement has done so much incredible work for reducing stigma around sex and having a lot of it and not too much about the stigma of not having any, despite the fact that they are both individual choices to do with bodily autonomy.
只是因为还没发生过而没有发生，这并不比有过很多性行为更能说明你的自我价值。老实说，我们在这个十年、在我们20多岁时、甚至在30多岁时，需要更多地讨论处女羞辱，因为A，处女羞辱和单身羞辱一样太普遍了。B，坦率地说，这是一种奇怪的行为。因为别人对自己的身体做出的选择而羞辱他们，这是一种奇怪的行为。有时我确实发现，性积极运动在减少关于性行为和拥有大量性行为的污名化方面做了大量不可思议的工作，但在减少“没有性行为”的污名化方面做得还不够，尽管这两者都是关于身体自主权的个人选择。
I want to bring in another study here, and it was a 22 study, that actually looked at the emotional consequences of virginity shaming among 30 adult virgins between the ages of 20 to 29. And it found that participants felt that virginity shaming made it hard for them to feel like they belonged. They felt that they weren't accepted for who they were and they had to justify or explain their choices when asked. They felt more shy when it came to approaching people.
我想在这里引入另一项研究，这是一项2022年的研究，它实际上探讨了30名年龄在20至29岁之间的成年处女中，处女羞辱带来的情感后果。研究发现，参与者认为处女羞辱让他们很难有归属感。他们觉得真实的自己不被接接受，当被问及选择时，他们不得不为自己的选择进行辩解或解释。他们在接近他人时感到更加害羞。
Not because they were naturally shy individuals. There was no correlation with introversion only because they felt like people were would be able to tell or would judge them, and they felt less desirable. And most of them also felt like they were running out of time, especially the women. Essentially, it can make us feel like everyone else is ahead in this made-up game of life and we better catch up quick. Again, my big, big question is why? Why do you need to catch up?
并不是因为他们天生就是害羞的人。这与内向没有任何相关性，只是因为他们觉得别人能看出来或者会评判他们，而且他们觉得自己更缺乏吸引力。他们大多数人还觉得自己的时间不多了，尤其是女性。本质上，这会让我们觉得在这个虚构的人生游戏中，其他人都遥遥领先，我们最好赶紧迎头赶上。同样，我巨大、巨大的疑问是：为什么？为什么你需要迎头赶上？
Just ask yourself that one now. Why? what is so good about the norm? What is so good about doing it the way everyone else has done it? So there are some other ways that we can be a late bloomer. I'm not really going to touch on them today, but in terms of career, professional milestones, moving out of home,
现在就问自己这个问题。为什么？常态到底有什么好？按其他人做过的方式去做到底有什么好？所以还有其他一些方式让我们成为大器晚成者。我今天不打算真正触及它们，但在职业生涯、职业里程碑、搬出家门、
finding friends, finding independence, all other valid ways. But I do really want to focus on relationships here. I really want to focus on being a late bloomer in love. And our main question now is, why is it so hard to feel at peace with the fact that you are going at your own pace or taking your time. Why is that so horrible?
寻找朋友、寻找独立方面，这都是其他有效的方式。但我确实非常想把重点放在情感关系上。我真的想把重点放在爱情上的大器晚成。我们现在的主要问题是，为什么对“你正按自己的节奏前行或放慢脚步”这一事实感到安心会这么难？为什么那会如此糟糕？
What's with the external but also internalized shame around being a late bloomer? Where does that come from? Let's talk about it. I think, first of all, it comes from this very romantic view of life whereby you find love early on and each step naturally leads you to the next and you've met your soulmate and you've done everything by the age of 16 and you're an adult and you're a big girl and you never hesitate and you're never alone. and you never doubt yourself, you never go backwards, and everything is forward, forward, forward.
对于作为一个大器晚成的晚熟者，那种外部的以及内化的羞耻感是怎么回事？那是从哪里来的？我们来谈谈吧。我想，首先，它来自于这种非常浪漫的人生观，即你很早就找到了真爱，每一步都自然而然地通向下一步，你遇到了你的灵魂伴侣，你在16岁之前就做完了所有的事情，你是个成年人了，你是个大女孩了，你从不犹豫，你从不孤单。
That's just not what it's honestly like when it comes to relationships and love and figuring yourself out as well. But we've been taught to embrace the linear typical timeline and to squeeze ourselves into the skin and life of someone who has done it all in seemingly the right time, even when that life is not right for us. And the alternative to not having done it that way is a lot of fomo, a lot of shame, a lot of sadness. So this whole experience has another name. It's called Social Clock Theory. So Social Clock Theory, this is the theory you need to know if you are experiencing a lot of late Bloomadred. It was introduced by the American psychologist Bernice Newarkarton back in the 60s and it basically refers to the culturally and socially constructed timeline for achieving
你从不怀疑自己，你从不倒退，一切都是向前、向前、向前。当谈到人际关系、爱情以及弄清楚你自己的时候，这根本不是真实的生活。但我们被教导去拥抱线性、典型的时间表，并把自己塞进一个似乎在正确的时间做完这一切的人的皮囊和生活中，即使那种生活根本不适合我们。而没有那样做所带来的替代品，就是大量的错失恐惧症（FOMO）、大量的羞耻感、大量的悲伤。所以整个经历还有一个名字。它被称为社会时钟理论。所以社会时钟理论，如果你正在经历很多晚熟焦虑，这就是你需要了解的理论。它是由美国心理学家伯尼斯·纽加滕在20世纪60年代提出的，它基本上是指为实现
major life milestones like graduating, securing a career, getting married. having children, having sex, all those things. Late bloomers, those of us who deviate from this expected timeline, they often experience social pressure, self-doubt, feeling behind, because of a social desire for conformity that they just haven't met. And, you know, there was even research back in the 90s that suggests that individuals who fall outside of the societal expectations in any of these ways, they really struggle with comparison and with love.
重大人生里程碑（如毕业、获得职业、结婚）而构建的文化和社会时间表。生孩子，发生性行为，所有这些事情。大器晚成者，我们这些偏离了这个预期时间表的人，经常会经历社会压力、自我怀疑、觉得自己落后了，因为有一种他们根本没有满足的社会同质化渴望。而且，你知道，早在90年代甚至就有研究表明，任何这些方面落后于社会预期的人，他们真的会在比较和爱情中挣扎。
self-esteem because naturally comparison is what a lot of this comes down to. We are naturally comparative creatures as well. And we do want to make sure we're doing it all right compared to the average because the alternative is that we're somehow doing it wrong. We're not like others. We're not normal and we're at a high risk of being ostracized. Now that fear of being ostracized is a very primal one, which is what makes it so hard to shut down. Even if rationally you know that it's all going to be okay, you're going to find love, you're going to have sex, you're going to do it all, you're just taking your time. When it comes to love in particular and relationships, I think our comparison evolves into something even harder to deal with called
自尊，因为很自然地，许多事情归根结底都是比较。我们天生也是善于比较的生物。我们确实希望确保与平均水平相比，我们把一切都做对了，因为另一种选择是我们不知怎么地做错了。我们与众不同。我们不正常，我们面临着被排斥的高风险。现在，这种被排斥的恐惧是一种非常原始的恐惧，这也是为什么它如此难以消除的原因。即使理性上你知道一切都会好起来的，你会找到真爱，你会发生性行为，你会完成这一切，你只是在放慢脚步。特别是对于爱情和人际关系，我认为我们的比较演变成了一种更难处理的东西，叫做
shiny object syndrome. Now this is actually an economics or like a consumer economics term. I like to adapt it to be used when it comes to comparison and wanting what we can't have. So it's not just that we feel inadequate, it's that we are then continually drawn and obsessed with the thing that we don't have, with this new shiny thing that everyone else has, that we just need to have at the expense of everything else. It's an obsession. You know, that shiny object, this shiny idea of love. We're so obsessed with it, we'll do anything for it. But then when we get it, we realize, Oh, you know, this is not really all that I was told it was going to be. This really like, yes, it's great, yes, it's fine, but I sacrificed so much to get this.
闪亮物件综合症。这实际上是一个经济学或消费经济学术语。我喜欢把它调整后用于比较和想要我们得不到的东西。所以这不仅是我们觉得不够好，而是我们随后不断地被我们没有的东西、被其他人拥有的那个我们不惜一切代价也必须拥有的新奇闪亮物件所吸引和痴迷。这是一种痴迷。你知道，那个闪亮的物件，这个关于爱的闪亮理念。我们太痴迷于它了，我们会为此做任何事。但当我们得到它时，我们意识到，哦，你知道，这其实并不像别人告诉我的那样。这真的——是的，很好，是的，没关系，但我为了得到它牺牲了太多。
Was it even worth it? Why did I feel like I was in such a rush? And it's because of the social impact and the social drive to fit in. Shiny object theory also explains why psychologically we don't believe that we will be happy if we don't have what everyone else has, something I'm sure many of you can relate to. So social clock theory is a really important one to know. And it also really links to, of course, milestone anxiety.
这真的值得吗？为什么我觉得自己如此匆忙？这是因为融入其中的社会影响和驱动力。闪亮物件理论也解释了为什么在心理上，如果我们没有其他人拥有的东西，我们就认为自己不会快乐，我确信你们很多人都能感同身受。所以社会时钟理论是一个非常重要的概念。它当然也与里程碑焦虑紧密相连。
This increasing sense of dread as time goes on that you are not reaching certain milestones when you should. So there was some research released in 2022 that some of you may have actually seen, and it polled around 2,000 young adults, and it asked them, in terms of where everyone else sits, in terms of what you think you should be doing,
随着时间的推移，这种不断加剧的恐惧感让你觉得自己在该达到的时候没有达到某些特定的里程碑。所以2022年发布了一些研究，你们中的一些人可能实际已经看到了，它调查了大约2000名年轻成年人，并问他们：就其他所有人所处的位置而言，就你认为自己应该在做什么而言，
where you think you should be, do you feel behind? I want you to just mentally, for me, how many of these individuals, from the age of 19 to 39, how many of them said I feel behind? Here's your answer. 80.
你认为自己应该在哪里，你觉得自己落后了吗？我希望你们在心里帮我算算，这些从19岁到39岁的人中，有多少人说“我觉得自己落后了”？答案在这里。80
percent well over a majority. It really begs the question, 80%. If eight out of 10 of us feel behind, why isn't feeling behind the norm? Why is it that the minority of people who feel like somehow they have it all together and have done it all correctly, why are they the ones who are doing it right? surely it seems that having a bit more fluidity and flexibility and kind of veering off the path every now and again, that seems like the right way to do it if the majority of people are doing it that way. And again, if I haven't said it already, who is making up these milestones? Like, I didn't give my input. I don't remember being invited to a focus group. I don't remember anyone asking me all these questions about when I had sex for the first time and when my first relationship was
这个比例远远超过了多数。这真的引出了一个问题，占80%。如果十分之八的人都觉得自己落后了，为什么“落后”没有成为常态？为什么那些少数觉得自己一切顺利、所有事情都做对的人，反倒成了做得对的人呢？显然，如果大多数人都是如此，那么生活多一点流动性、灵活性，偶尔偏离一下轨道，似乎才是正确的做法。再说一次，如果我之前还没说过的话，这些人生里程碑究竟是谁制定出来的？我可没有发表意见。我不记得自己被邀请参加过什么焦点小组。我不记得有人问过我这些问题，比如我第一次性爱是什么时候，我的第一段恋爱是什么时候
and putting it into a big spreadsheet to find the average, in many, many ways, these milestones and the ages attached to them are imaginary. It doesn't mean it doesn't still feel hard and distressing and uncomfortable when we don't conform, but I want you to remember, it's not as real and tangible as you think it is. No one is comparing you to some factual spreadsheet
然后把它们放进一个大表格里计算平均值。在很多很多方面，这些里程碑以及与之相伴的年龄都是凭空想象出来的。这并不意味着当我们不合群时，那种艰难、痛苦和不适感就不存在了，但我希望你记住，它并没有你想象的那么真实和具象。没有人会拿你和一个真实的电子表格去对比
that has the exact age number of months that you should have completed this by. So at the end of the day, we do still know this is difficult. What are some of the emotional consequences of being a late bloomer in this world? And what do we do about it? What do we do about it when just getting into a relationship, just getting out there and dating isn't really an option? Well, we are going to talk about all of that as well as so, so much more how to date as a late bloomer, some of the biggest anxieties that we deal with after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
上面有你应该完成这一切的确切年龄数字的月份。所以归根结底，我们仍然知道这很困难。在这个世界上，作为一个大器晚成的晚熟者，一些情感后果是什么？我们该怎么办？当仅仅去谈恋爱、仅仅走出去约会并不是真正的一种选择时，我们该怎么办？好吧，我们将在短暂的休息后讨论所有这些以及更多内容：如何作为大器晚成的晚熟者去约会，我们在经历这些时需要应对的一些最大焦虑。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个古怪现代世界中的心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透充斥在健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们真的搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们在世界上所担忧的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。就在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，搜索数字 2 PERCENT。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和李尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集节目中，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何撑过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
畅谈80年代的快克（霹雳可卡因）。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我可以一整天都在聊快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的，我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important year. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Keer Games）。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却仍然在盲目追逐，
and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
并且不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是像看记分牌一样盯着结果。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
完全正确。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她言词中明显的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场历时多年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你伪造了某个特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。
that Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We've already spoken about a few of the consequences that we face of being a late bloomer. One we haven't spoken about yet is shame. If you are a late bloomer, I'm sure that shame is a frequent emotion in, your emotional toolkit. I want to read you, another story from a listener here, about the shame of not having done at all on this imaginary timeline. Here we go. I'm 21 and I haven't even held hands
马里科帕县（Ameriopa County）宣布，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。我们已经讨论过成为“大器晚成者”所面临的一些后果。我们还没讨论过的一个后果就是羞耻感。如果你是大器晚成者，我确信羞耻感是你情感工具箱中经常出现的一种情绪。我想给你读一读这里一位听众的故事，关于在这个虚构的时间线上没有完成所有事情的羞耻感。我们开始吧。我21岁了，甚至没有在浪漫意义上牵过手，
romantically or had my first kiss. There is a lot of shame surrounding this. I feel so inexperienced like no one will want me because I don't know what I'm doing. I'm definitely an introvert and struggle putting myself out there. One part of me has ignored. that I'm still so young. Why rush? My time will come. I will find someone who loves me. The other part of me continues to find that this shame comes and goes in waves. I want to say this. I actually asked a group of my friends at dinner the other night. There's about 14 of us at dinner, some men, some women, some queer, some heterosexual. I like put it towards the table. Would you hesitate to date someone because they were inexperienced?
或者有过初吻。这周围有很多羞耻感。我觉得自己太没有经验了，好像没有人会想要我，因为我不知道自己在做什么。我绝对是个内向的人，很难向外界敞开心扉。我内心的一部分忽略了我还这么年轻的事实。为什么要着急？我的时代会到来。我会找到一个爱我的人。我内心的另一部分不断发现，这种羞耻感会一波一波地袭来。我想说的是。我前几天在晚饭时实际上问了我的一群朋友。我们大约有14个人在吃饭，有些是男人，有些是女人，有些是酷儿，有些是异性恋。我把它抛向了大家。你会因为某人没有经验而犹豫和他们约会吗？
Not one of them said yes. all of them says that doesn't really matter to me as long as we click. Some people even said, hey, it might even be an upside, might even be a positive thing, because they're not jaded. They have less baggage. We get to experience this, like I feel like I'll get to experience what it feels like to fall in love for the first time, again with this person because it's all fresh and new to them. But that battle between trying to be hopeful and also succumbing to shame is a very common one.
没有一个人说“会”。所有人都说，只要我们合得来，这对我来说真的不重要。有些人甚至说，嘿，这甚至可能是一个优势，甚至可能是一件积极的事情，因为他们没有饱经沧桑。他们有更少的包袱。我们可以体验到这种感觉，就像我觉得我能再次体验到初恋的感觉一样，和这个人一起，因为这一切对他们来说都是新鲜的。但是，在试图保持希望和屈服于羞耻感之间的这种斗争是非常普遍的。
you've got to remember shame is a social emotion no human child person it naturally comes out of the womb feeling shame it's something that is taught to you it is something that you have been made to feel so i want you to interrogate and really think when was the first time i was made to feel ashamed for this what was that person probably thinking what were they projecting onto me and why in the world was it any of their business. Another emotional consequence, another side of this is also fear. We've spoken about this a little bit, but what if it never happens? What if I never find love? It's probably a bit scary to even hear me say that, right? Firstly, I'm just going to say it. It's highly unlikely. It's highly unlikely. It's going to clear that up for you. It just hasn't been your time yet. Doesn't
你必须记住，羞耻感是一种社会情绪，没有哪个幼儿、哪个人生来就会感到羞耻，这是后天教给你的，是让你感到羞耻的东西。所以我希望你去质问并认真思考：我第一次因此感到羞耻是什么时候？那个人当时可能在想什么？他们在我身上投射了什么？为什么这世界上的任何事情都与他们有关？另一个情感后果，这方面的另一个方面也是恐惧。我们已经讨论过一点了，但是如果这一切从未发生呢？如果我从未找到真爱呢？听到我这么说可能有点吓人，对吧？首先，我要这么说。这极不可能。这极不可能。我会为你澄清这一点。只是你的时间还没到。并不
mean it won't happen. And I'm allowed to say this. I feel like I have permission to say this because I have seen this happen again and again and again. I have seen friends of mine who were in their 30s and never had a serious relationship find someone. I have seen people who are 27, 28, never had sex, never had a kiss, and suddenly it just all starts happening for them. It's okay to feel afraid of that possibility. I think the reason that we do feel particularly afraid of what it would be like to never have that experience is because there are very few examples of what that looks like. You know, there are very few people out there who are open about being a virgin at 40. There are very few influencers who are 50 and have never been in a relationship.
意味着它不会发生。而且我有权这么说。我觉得我有资格这么说，因为我一次又一次、一次又一次地看到这种情况发生。我见过我的朋友在30多岁、从未有过认真恋爱经历时找到了另一半。我见过27、28岁、从未有过性经验、从未有过初吻的人，突然间这一切都为他们发生了。对这种可能性感到害怕是正常的。我认为我们之所以对从未有过这种经历会是什么样子感到特别害怕，是因为这种样子的例子太少了。你知道，外面很少有人公开承认自己在40岁时还是处女。很少有50岁、从未谈过恋爱的人还作为网红活跃着。
And that means that if you're 20 or 19 or 25 or 28 or whatever age you are, looking for some sign that you will be okay, even if it doesn't happen, you aren't going to struggle to find one because the stigma likes to keep those people silent. And so therefore you will struggle to feel like it is acceptable. and the fear of it not happening is going to be a lot bigger. To that fear, let me also say this. 85% of our worst fears never come true. It's probably an even higher number.
这意味着如果你20岁、19岁、25岁、28岁或无论你多大年龄，在寻找一些迹象表明即使没有发生你也会没事的，你不会费力去寻找，因为社会污迹喜欢让这些人保持沉默。因此，你会很难觉得这是可以接受的。而它没有发生的恐惧将会大得多。对于这种恐惧，我还想说：我们最坏的恐惧中有85%永远不会成真。这个数字可能更高。
It's probably something around 90%. And for the 10, 15% that might come true, studies have continuously shown that people handle those situations, the very situations they feared more than any other. Way better than they expected they would. way better than they thought that they ever could. So even if it never happens,
可能在90%左右。而对于那可能成真的10%到15%，研究不断表明，人们在处理这些情况时——正是他们最害怕的情况——比其他任何情况都要好得多。比他们预期的要好得多。比他们曾经想象的要好得多。所以即使它从未发生，
what's to say you still won't have an amazing life, you still won't be deeply happy, have love in other forms. I think in order to release our shame around being a late bloomer, we have to let go of the fear that if things were never to change, we wouldn't necessarily be miserable. You would be okay.
谁说你仍然不会拥有精彩的生活，你仍然不会深感幸福，在其他形式中拥有爱。我认为为了释放我们作为大器晚成者的羞耻感，我们必须放手这种恐惧：如果事情永远不会改变，我们不一定会痛苦。你会没事的。
you are going to be okay and I have seen it happen I just really I know I've already said this but oh my gosh I just wish I could tell you how many times I have seen single friends of mine find their first relationship start dating for the first time at 35 or even older or had sex for the first time in their late 20s and just found that suddenly one day the circumstances are perfect the right person just walks in and because they didn't rush or settle like so many of us. They have all the maturity and readiness to be 100% in, 100% committed, and they get to have all those experiences they've ever dreamed of. I'll also say this, sorry, I'm not even done with my point yet. I think the reason that you're convinced it will never happen
你会没事的，我见过这种情况发生。我真的——我知道我已经说过这个了，但天哪，我真希望我能告诉你，我见过多少次单身朋友找到他们的第一段恋情，在35岁或更大年龄时第一次开始约会，或者在20多岁快结束时第一次发生性关系，然后发现突然有一天，情况变得完美，对的人就这样走进来，因为他们没有像我们许多人那样匆忙或将就。他们拥有百分之百投入、百分之百承诺的所有成熟度和准备，他们得到了他们一直梦想的所有体验。我还要说这个，对不起，我还没说完我的观点。我认为你之所以坚信它永远不会发生，
is because you don't know what it will feel like when it does. You can only ruminate on what you do know, which is where you are right now, which is the situation in which it hasn't happened yet. that is the only feeling that you are familiar with. And so that feeling is so much stronger than the alternative feeling of knowing what it feels like to be in love. So always, what is known, what is normal, what is status quo for you is going to dominate over possibility. And so the voice in your head that's saying, this is what it's always going to be like
是因为你不知道当它发生时会是什么感觉。你只能反刍你所知道的，也就是你现在所处的地方，也就是它还没有发生的情况。那是你唯一熟悉的感觉。所以这种感觉比了解恋爱感觉的替代感觉要强大得多。所以总是这样，已知的东西、正常的东西、对你来说的现状将支配可能性。所以你脑海中说“事情将永远是这样”的声音，
is naturally going to be so much louder than the part of you who is saying, hey, but look at this situation that could potentially happen. hasn't happened yet, there's less salience to it, there's less depth to it, it feels less believable, doesn't mean that it is. So with all of this in mind, I want to talk about how we can embrace being a late bloomer and feel more confident when dating, when putting ourselves out there, but also more confident with taking our time. I'm going to start this section by giving you an affirmation here. and it's a quote that actually came from Milan, the movie. It's one of the most beautiful things I've ever heard.
自然会比那个说“嘿，但是看看这个可能发生的情况”的你的一部分要大得多。它还没有发生，它的显著性较低，深度较小，感觉不那么可信，但这并不意味着它是这样的。因此，鉴于所有这一切，我想谈谈我们如何拥抱作为一个大器晚成者的身份，在约会时、在将自己展示给世界时感觉更自信，同时也更有信心慢慢来。我将通过给你一个肯定来开始这一部分，这是一个实际上来自电影《花木兰》的名言。这是我听过的最美丽的事情之一。
The last flower to bloom is the most beautiful of all, and it's normally the one that blooms the longest. And I found that very much to be true. There's another quote that I think accompanies this one. You should never trust an elevator that rises too fast because it doesn't last. And the reason I think it's necessary to bring. these up is because it highlights an important truth. The slower you think you're moving through life, the more you are actually getting to experience and take it all in. The less you're
迟开的花朵是最美丽的，而且它通常是开得最久的花。我发现这非常真实。还有另一句我认为与这一句相伴的名言。你永远不应该信任上升得太快的电梯，因为它不会持久。我认为有必要提出这些的原因是因为它突出了一个重要的真理。你认为自己在生活中移动得越慢，你实际上得到的体验和吸收就越多。你越不
rushing, meaning the longer you get to be in the process of blooming rather than fully blossomed, fully flowered, rather than at the final stage of development thinking, oh, I got here so fast, I didn't even get to enjoy my own evolution. Now, I've spoken. spoken to people about this who have seemingly found everything very, very early on. We would assume, or as a late bloomer, it would be very easy for you to assume that they must be really, really happy, that they must not have any doubts about their future. Actually, it's quite the opposite. One of the sentiments I actually hear a lot that people, you know, they're not very loud about because it feels strange to talk about, but it's a sentiment I actually hear from a lot
匆忙，这意味着你在绽放过程中呆的时间就越长，而不是完全盛开，完全开花，而不是在发展的最后阶段认为，“哦，我这么快就到了这里，我甚至没有时间享受我自己的进化。”现在，我已经谈过了。我和那些似乎很早就找到了一切的人谈过这件事。我们会假设，或者作为一个大器晚成者，你很容易假设他们一定真的非常高兴，他们对自己的未来一定没有任何疑问。实际上，恰恰相反。我经常听到的一种情绪是，人们，你知道，他们声音不是很大，因为谈论它感觉很奇怪，但这是我确实从很多
of my friends who found their long-term partner quite young. And I'm talking under the age of 26, 25. A lot of them say, I wish that I got to enjoy being single a little bit longer. I wish that I had not rushed so fast. I wish that I had just known it was going to happen and just let myself enjoy the single period for a longer time with more ease. You know, the grass is always green. I think my biggest tip is to remember this, is to remember there is absolutely no way of knowing, no way of knowing that if it had happened any differently, you would be any happier. But secondly, that doesn't mean you don't get to grieve the early experiences that you wish you'd had.
很年轻就找到长期伴侣的朋友那里听到的一种情绪。我说的是26岁、25岁以下。他们中的许多人说，我希望我能享受更长时间的单身生活。我希望我没有那么匆忙。我希望我早知道它会发生，然后让自己更轻松地享受更长时间的单身期。你知道，草总是绿的。我认为我最大的建议是记住这一点，记住绝对没有办法知道，没有办法知道如果事情以任何不同方式发生，你是否会更快乐。但其次，这并不意味着你不被允许为那些你希望自己拥有过的早期经历感到悲伤。
As much as I'm trying to convince you that it's not as important as you think, you can take your time, that's very easy for me to say considering that I've had them. And I know that if you haven't, it can really feel like you've missed out. it's okay to be sad about that. If not for you right now, even if you're happy right now, it's okay to be sad for the version of you who really wanted it to happen, but then we have to get focused on the future. And counter to what you might think.
尽管我试图让你相信它不像你想象的那么重要，你可以慢慢来，但考虑到我已经经历过这些，我说这话很容易。我知道如果你没有，你真的会觉得你错过了。为此感到难过是可以的。如果现在不是为你，即使你现在很高兴，为那个真正希望它发生的版本的你感到难过是可以的，但我们必须专注于未来。与你可能认为的相反，
Just because it hasn't happened doesn't make you any less desirable, any less attractive, you can still have a really rewarding dating life. And a really amazing dating life, actually. I'm going to even, I'm going to bump it up here. You can still have the best dating life just because it hasn't happened yet. And I think that really means sinking very deeply into, you know, what makes you unique and knowing what makes you really, really happy and knowing that the asset you have now is that you have greater maturity, you're more independent, you have all these other life lessons
仅仅因为它还没有发生并不能让你变得不那么令人向往，不那么有吸引力，你仍然可以拥有一个非常充实的约会生活。事实上，还有一个非常棒的约会生活。我甚至要，我要在这里提升一下。仅仅因为它还没有发生，你仍然可以拥有最好的约会生活。我认为这真的意味着深深地沉浸在，你知道，是什么让你变得独特，知道是什么让你真的非常快乐，并知道你现在拥有的资产是你有更高的成熟度，你更独立，你拥有所有这些其他的生活生活教训，
that other people may have neglected in their like obsessive pursuit of life. love. So if you're in that phase of being like, all right, cool, I'm feeling insecure about this, but I want to get back out there. I want you to start by trying to cut out the rumination and do things that you find interesting and that make you interesting and that you think are interesting. So I'm talking confidence through, I guess, confidence through opportunity and experience and passion. Put yourself into group situations doing things you love. Join Roller Derby, join field hockey, join a ceramics class. Get yourself around people, get yourself feeling alive.
其他人可能在他们对生活、爱的痴迷追求中忽略了这些。所以如果你正处于那种觉得，“好吧，酷，我对这个感到不安全，但我想重新开始”的阶段，我希望你首先尝试切断胡思乱想，做那些你觉得有趣、能让你变得有趣并且你认为有趣的事情。所以我在谈论通过，我猜，通过机会、经验和激情获得的自信。把自己放进做你热爱的事情的团体情境中。加入轮滑，加入曲棍球，加入陶瓷课。让自己周围有人，让自己感到活着。
Find groups that align with your interests and insert yourself into them. Show up, be present, talk to people. Let me say this. For all the emphasis on dating apps, the meet cute is not dead. And I know that dating apps can feel really overwhelming if you haven't had some of those early dating experiences. You can meet people without them. like I'm saying this as someone who literally sometimes does advertisements for dating apps, they are not absolutely necessary.
寻找与你的兴趣相符的团体并将自己融入其中。出现，保持存在，与人交谈。让我这么说吧。尽管所有人都强调约会软件，但美好的邂逅并没有消亡。我知道，如果你没有过一些早期的约会经历，约会软件会让你感到非常不知所措。你可以在没有它们的情况下结识人。就像我作为一个字面意义上有时为约会软件做广告的人在说这样的话，它们绝对不是必需的。
You can still meet amazing people face to face. And maybe that's what's more comfortable for you because you get to actually know them and have a friendship first, which feels more authentic. So my first big tip, get into groups, get into communities where you feel aligned with people. Secondly, make a bucket list of things that you. want to do that have nothing to do with love and sex and relationships. Sometimes I find when there's this one thing that we feel we're missing out on, all we can think about is that one thing. It's the shiny object syndrome, right? My God, there's this shiny thing and I'm obsessed
你仍然可以面对面地结识了不起的人。也许这更适合你，因为你可以真正了解他们并首先建立友谊，这感觉更真实。所以我的第一个大建议，加入团体，进入让你觉得与人合拍的社区。其次，列一个愿望清单，列出你想做的事情，这些事情与爱情、性和关系完全无关。有时我发现，当有这样一件我们觉得自己错过了的事情时，我们所能想到的就是那件事。这就是闪亮物体综合症，对吧？天哪，有这个闪亮的东西，我很着迷
with it, and if I don't have it, I'm going to die. It's going to be awful. I'm going to be miserable. That's the only thing that's going to make me happy. Stop. No, that's a fallacy. Your brain is trying to tell you. You can be happy doing a hell of a lot more things. So I want you to make a bucket list of all the things that you really want to do to make sure you're continuing to put time into yourself even though you feel maybe held back by being a late bloomer. Make sure that your life is just overflowing in every other area. I also want you to make a second list of things that you can only do when you're single that your future self is going to thank you for doing now. And let me tell you this. They're going to thank you. I did this when I was single and I'm so glad I did because
有了它，如果我没有它，我就会死。这会很糟糕。我会很痛苦。这是唯一能让我快乐的事情。停下。不，那是谬论。你的大脑试图告诉你。你可以通过做更多的事情来获得快乐。所以我希望你列一个愿望清单，列出所有你真正想做的事情，以确保你继续把时间投入到自己身上，尽管你可能觉得被大器晚成者的身份阻碍了。确保你的生活在所有其他领域都溢满。我还希望你列出第二份清单，列出那些只有在你单身时才能做的事情，你未来的自己会感谢你现在所做的。让我告诉你这个。他们会感谢你的。我单身时这样做过，我很高兴我这样做了，因为
When you have shared a bed with someone for like the 5,000th night in a row, sometimes you miss being single and in your own bed and just like getting to do whatever you want it. Like there are actual perks to having like that freedom and like just agency to just do anything and not have to consider someone else and not have to think about their opinion and not have to, you know, not have to really understand that you're doing this as a partnership. and just have some fun with your single life. I also want you to, if you're getting back into dating, treat dating as an experiment and take it in stages.
当你和一个人共享一张床连续大约第5,000个夜晚时，有时你会怀念单身并在自己的床上以及只是做你想做的事情的感觉。就像拥有那种自由和代理权去做任何事情而不必考虑别人而不必考虑他们的意见而不必，你知道，不必真正理解你作为伴侣在做这件事有实际好处。并享受你的单身生活。我还希望你，如果你要重新开始约会，把约会当作一个实验，分阶段进行。
It can feel very overwhelming to go from not dating, not having anything romantic really happening to you, to being like, oh my God, I'm on five dates in a week, and this is exhausting and I have to talk to all these people, and I just can't manage the emotional intensity of it. So take it in stages. Start by just having conversations with people you find attractive. You're allowed to talk.
从不约会、没有任何浪漫的事情发生在你身上，到“哦，天哪，我一周有五个约会，这太累了，我必须和所有人交谈，我只是无法应付它带来的情感强度”，这会让人感到非常不知所措。所以分阶段来。首先只是和那些你觉得有吸引力的人交谈。你可以说话。
to people you find attractive. I was like, oh, they don't want to talk to me. Who gives a fuck? You're cool. Who cares? Like, you're a cool person. If they don't want to talk to you, like they're an asshole. Talk to them. Even if you feel judged, even if you feel embarrassed, whatever, who cares? That's their problem. You're a catch. You're an absolute catch. Also, you'll be surprised by how much of that is in your own head and how many people do actually find you really interesting and fun and want to talk to you and find you attractive. Secondly, download the dating apps if you want, but for the first little bit, just like people. Like, just engage with their profiles.
对你觉得有吸引力的人。我当时想，哦，他们不想和我说话。谁他妈在乎？你很酷。谁在乎？就像，你是一个很酷的人。如果他们不想和你说话，就像他们是个混蛋。和他们说话。即使你觉得自己被评判了，即使你觉得尴尬，无论如何，谁在乎？那是他们的问题。你是个宝藏。你绝对是个宝藏。此外，你会惊讶于其中有多少是出于你自己的脑海，有多少人实际上真的觉得你很有趣、很好玩、想和你说话并觉得你有吸引力。其次，如果你愿意，下载约会软件，但在最初的一小段时间里，就像人一样。就像，只是和他们的个人资料互动。
Don't go out with anyone. Don't do any of that. Practice some flirting. I want you to just start by liking people. I just want you to start by seeing that people like you back. Then start by talking to people. Please be picky. I do not want to see you giving likes out or swiping left, right?
不要和任何人约会。不要做任何那种事。练习一些调情。我希望你从点赞别人开始。我只想让你开始看到别人也对你点赞。然后开始和人交谈。请挑剔一点。我不想看到你把赞送出去或者向左滑动，对吧？
Swiping yes. I don't know which way it is anymore. Swiping yes on people who you aren't attracted to, we are not settling in this moment. We are not saying, oh, well, you know, they look like they'd accept me. They look like, like, I can't be picky. I can't go for the hot ones.
向右滑动。我不知道到底是哪一个了。对你不感兴趣的人向右滑动，我们在这个时刻不会将就。我们不会说，“哦，好吧，你知道，他们看起来会接受我。他们看起来像，就像，我不能挑剔。我不能选那些辣的。”
I can't go for the people who seem more experienced. None of that. We are only engaging with people on the dating apps who we would genuinely really like to date and think are really attractive and cool. Once you have just started to talk to people, I want you to wait for someone to ask you out.
我不能去找那些看起来更有经验的人。这些都不行。我们只在约会软件上与那些我们真心想约会、觉得非常有吸引力且很酷的人互动。一旦你开始和别人聊天，我希望你等到有人约你出去。
Now, normally, I would say, go and ask someone else out. Go and just like, shoot your shot. I think you deserve for someone to ask you out. I think that you deserve to have that experience. So, wait for them. You have plenty of years to ask other people out. If it's going to be your first day,
现在，通常情况下，我会说，去约别人出去。去，就像，主动出击。我认为你值得有人约你出去。我认为你值得拥有那种体验。所以，等他们。你有好几年的时间去约别人出去。如果这将是你的第一次约会，
if you're just starting out again, make them come to you. It will make you feel confident. It will make you feel desired. And then, go on a date. Oh my gosh, how fun. I have a whole episode on this called How to Have Better First Dates. Genuinely, the amount of DMs and comments I get from people saying,
如果你才刚刚重新开始，让他们来找你。这会让你感到自信。这会让你感到被渴望。然后，去约会。哦，天哪，多有趣啊。我有一整集关于这个的节目叫《如何拥有更好的第一次约会》。老实说，我从人们那里得到的私信和评论的数量说，
this is how I met my partner, I used those tips and suddenly I didn't feel nervous anymore, had the best first date of my life, now we've been dating. I love that episode, listen to that episode. But also, remember, your main objective here is to have fun and learn things about yourself. Dating is a lot. Meeting new people is a lot. sometimes you need to disconnect from the event and the significance of it for you to really enjoy it. I have a friend who she also took a while to start dating and when she went on those first few dates,
这就是我遇到伴侣的方式，我用了那些技巧，突然间我不再紧张了，有了我一生中最棒的第一次约会，现在我们一直在约会。我喜欢那一集，去听那一集吧。但是，也要记住，你这里的主要目标是玩得开心并了解关于你自己的事情。约会是一件大事。结识新的人是一件大事。有时你需要从事件及其对你的重要性中脱离出来，才能真正享受它。我有一个朋友，她也花了一段时间才开始约会，当她去参加前几次约定时，
it was so nerve-wracking and she really couldn't get over the mental barrier of it. So I told her, I want you to think of it like you're writing an article. Like she's a journalist and I was like, you know, when you go on those dates, you're like, yes, you're there to have the date, but you're also there to like investigate. you're there to like get information. Or I want you to imagine that like you're on this date but actually you're on a TV show. We just want some kind of cognitive distancing so you don't just think, oh my God, it's a first date, it's a date and this is so intense and it has to go well. This is just experimental for you.
这太让人紧张了，她真的无法克服心理障碍。所以我告诉她，我希望你把它想象成你在写一篇文章。就像她是一个记者，我说，“你知道，当你去那些约会时，你是对的，你在那里约会，但你也在那里调查。你在那里获取信息。或者我想象你就像在这次约会中，但实际上你是在一个电视节目中。我们只想要某种认知距离，这样你才不会只是想，‘哦，天哪，这是第一次约会，这是一个约会，这太强烈了，它必须进展顺利。’这只是你的实验。
Remember you're in your experimental phase. You're just getting to know yourself more through this dating period. It's going to be scary. It's going to be scary. But being scared is actually an important part of the process. I also want you to remember two final things. If someone is on a date with you, if someone is talking to you, they are doing that by choice. You know, if they didn't want to be there, they wouldn't be there.
记住你处于实验阶段。你只是在这个约会期间更多地了解自己。这会很可怕。这会很可怕。但害怕实际上是这个过程的重要部分。我还想让你记住最后两件事。如果有人在和你约会，如果有人在和你说话，他们是出于选择这样做的。你知道，如果他们不想在那里，他们就不会在那里。
They are at the very least, a little bit curious about you. Before you start overthinking as well, I want you to also remember, you cannot say the wrong thing to the right person. Please, please be authentically yourself. You have worked so hard to be that way for your. entire life, don't give it up now just because you have this potential of getting into a relationship. Let me just say this. Yes, the right relationship is amazing. If it's the wrong relationship, it's just a waste of your fucking time. So please don't settle. You know, there's a 2013 study that I think of all the time when I give people this advice. I quote it always. And it's about
他们至少对你有点好奇。在你开始过度思考之前，我也想让你记住，你不能对正确的人说错话。请，请真实地做你自己。你为了成为这样的人付出了如此多的努力，一辈子都在这样做，不要仅仅因为你有进入关系的这种潜力就放弃它。让我这么说吧。是的，正确的关系是惊人的。如果它是错误的关系，那只是浪费你的他妈的时间。所以请不要将就。你知道，2013年有一项研究，当我给人们这个建议时，我一直在想。我总是引用它。它是关于
how people who have an innate fear of being single actually tend to settle for a whole lot less. and the people who end up settling, when they come back to them in two years' time, they are a whole lot less happy compared to people who were also in the experiment who stayed single for that same amount of time. So we've got two groups of people here, the people who settled, the people who said, no, I like you I am. I'm going to stay this way and wait for the right person. That group was happier. I want you to be part of that group. Please, do not settle for less.
那些对单身有先天恐惧的人实际上倾向于将就很多更少的东西。而那些最终将就的人，当他们在两年后回到他们身边时，与那些也在实验中并在同一时间内保持单身的人相比，他们要快乐得多。所以我们这里有两组人，将就的人，说“不，我喜欢我现在的样子。我要保持这样并等待对的人”的人。那一组更快乐。我希望你成为那个组的一部分。请，不要将就更少。
Be authentic. You cannot say the wrong thing to the right person. you will lose nothing, nothing, nothing, nothing. You only have things to gain by showing up as your true self. I want to finish up this episode doing two things. Firstly, is I want to talk about the pros of being a late bloomer, and then I want to finish on a story. Let's quickly go through some pros for when you're feeling shitty about your circumstances,
保持真实。你不能对正确的人说错话。你不会失去任何东西，任何东西，任何东西，任何东西。通过以真实的自我出现，你只有东西可以获得。我想以两件事结束这一集。首先，我想谈谈作为一个大器晚者的优点，然后我想以一个故事结束。让我们快速浏览一些优点，当你的情况让你觉得糟透了，
maybe a bit uncomfortable, upset about how it's gone so far. if you've never been in a relationship, that shows great strength because I bet you've had opportunities and you've chosen not to settle. Even if you didn't realize you had opportunities unconsciously, your brain has been like, yeah, that's not for us. You as a late bloomer are a lot more mature. You're a lot more intuitive. You are going to be better at advocating for yourself in a relationship compared to, you know, 14 and 15-year-old you who didn't know themselves as well. You can be more present in your experiences. You can make choices that align better with who you are.
也许有点不舒服，对事情迄今为止的进展感到不安时，如果你从未谈过恋爱，这表现出巨大的力量，因为我敢打赌你曾有过机会，但你选择不将就。即使你没有意识到你在潜意识里有机会，你的大脑也一直在说，“是的，那不适合我们。”作为大器晚者，你更加成熟。你更加直观。与不懂自己的14、15岁的你相比，你将更擅长在关系中为自己辩护。你可以在你的体验中更加在场。你可以做出更符合你是谁的选择。
Also, it's going to feel more special. Like, seriously, it's going to feel so much more special. And you've had time to understand your needs and your wants. That means that you're less likely to make some of the stupid mistakes that people make when they start dating and having sex really early on. And you're going to be more grounded. You're going to be more grounded in who you are, what you want, and in the beauty and the magic of your relationship.
此外，这会感觉更特别。就像，说真的，这会感觉特别得多。你已经有时间了解你的需求和想要。这意味着你不太可能犯那些很早开始约会和发生性关系的人所犯的一些愚蠢错误。你会更脚踏实地。你将在你是谁、你想要什么以及你的关系的魔力中更加脚踏实地。
I want to finish with this story, and I actually found this story on Reddit, but I just think it is so wonderful. So this came from a page on Reddit, which was advice for late bloomers. Here we go. I think I appreciate my wife so much more because I missed the whole prom, homecoming, early dating stuff, early in life.
我想以这个故事结束，我实际上在Reddit上找到了这个故事，但我认为它太棒了。所以这来自Reddit上的一个页面，也就是给大器晚者的建议。我们开始吧。我想我更加感激我的妻子，因为我错过了整个舞会、返校节、早期的约会东西，在生命早期。
My name was not written on anyone's trapper keeper. No girl's dad had to warn me to bring home their kid before 11pm. I missed all that. So when I dated later in my 20s, I made sure to be the best man I could be. Even now, I'm still trying to live up to that, but everything just feels so much more special and important that I think it would have felt if I'd done all this younger. How beautiful is that?
我的名字没有写在任何人的文件夹上。没有女孩的爸爸不得不警告我在晚上11点之前把他们的孩子带回家。我错过了所有这些。所以当我在20多岁后期约会时，我确保成为我能成为的最好的人。即使现在，我仍在努力达到那个标准，但一切都感觉比我年轻时做所有这一切要特别得多、重要得多。这多美啊！
How absolutely beautiful is that? And that is the tone I want to finish this episode on. So thank you, my lovely, lovely late bloomer listeners. I say that five times. Thank you for listening. Oh my gosh, say that five times. Thank you so much for listening. I really do appreciate you getting here, getting this far into the episode.
这绝对多美啊！这就是我想结束这一集的基调。所以谢谢你，我可爱的大器晚者听众们。我说五遍。谢谢你们收听。哦，天哪，说五遍。非常感谢你们收听。我真的很感激你们能来到这里，走到这一集。
I hope you feel confident at ease. hear your affirmations and what makes you feel better about being a late bloomer in the comments. I know so many people ask me for this episode and so many people could really gain something from your personal wisdom. So please share below. Connect with other late blooms. I want to hear from you. Make sure that you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. I've got a book coming out soon and there's going to be so much on there about what that was like and, you know, fun. chapters and sneak peeks and previews and events that we've got probably coming to your city. So I would love to connect with you over there.
我希望你感到自信轻松。在评论中听到你的肯定以及什么让你对作为一个大器晚者感觉更好。我知道很多人向我索要这一集，很多人真的可以从你的个人智慧中获益。所以请在下面分享。与其他大器晚成者建立联系。我想听到你的声音。确保你在Instagram上关注我 @that psychology podcast。我很快就会出一本书，上面会有很多关于那是什么样的内容，你知道，有趣的章节和先睹为快以及我们可能来到你城市的活动。所以我很乐意在那里与你建立联系。
I would love to hear from you. I'd love to hear your thoughts on this episode. Any further contributions. And yeah, until next time, make sure you rate us five stars. Make sure you are following along and stay safe. Be kind. Please, please, please, please be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon.
我很乐意听到你的消息。我很乐意听到你对这一集的看法。任何进一步的贡献。是的，直到下一次，确保给我们评五星。确保你一直在关注并保持安全。保持善良。请，请，请，请对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会谈话。
2%. That is the number of people. people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the
2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个古怪现代世界中的心理韧性、健身以及建立适应力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透充斥在健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们真的搞错了。我们在世界上所担忧的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。就在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，搜索数字2 PERCENT。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和李尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集节目中，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何撑过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so, yeah, yeah. No, we don't have plenty. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct.
其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，畅谈80年代的快克（霹雳可卡因）。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我可以一整天都在聊快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, learn the hard way with me. your host and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的平台上收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却仍然在盲目追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算“够了”。因为人们总是像看记分牌一样盯着结果。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor's. star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones.
学习“难走的路”。打开您免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试。我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑爆炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio, app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
这是“爱情陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌诈骗被起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈HAEL·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一边成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听2%。
That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
那是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听的“TWO”。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at It Podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“The Girlfriends. Trust Me, Babe”。在“The Look Back at It Podcast”节目中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个大时刻。84年对我来说很大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not have. mean that you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iHeart radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的“Learn the Hardway”。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Learn the Hardway”
podcast this is an iHeart podcast guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客，保证是人类制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。